hello everyone and welcome to this
incredible position from yesterday's
gookish versus niponishi game where a
rook the G6 was played and nipple played
Knight captures on H7 which loses the
game on the spot but gukash has to find
the precise way to do it and he does
Knights the d8 with check forces King to
A7 and a captures on B5 now look at this
B6 B7 check is coming so Knight to f8
attacks The Rook now B6 shot King to A6
and pawn to B7 offering a rook for uh
promoting the pawn to a queen you have
to prevent this and now Google finishes
the game with a nice Rook to A6 check
and he was in this position on move 62
that nepo resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here you
either capture and allow the queen into
the game or you play King to B8 and then
a nice forcing checkmating sequence in
four moves uh Rook day 7 checking here
and now ironite the C6 or E6 or F7 uh
will be a nice Force Checkmate so that's
the that's the game hope you enjoyed it
see you soon